the night is dark and stormy at the
beach a crowd raised to the thunder in
the skies
all hail the god of chaos who sleeps no
more
Cthulhu the great green bringer of
Madness Rises
a colossal Shadow emerges from the ocean
wielding tentacles wings and eyes that
reach deep into your soul
and your mind if Cthulhu the terrifying
demigod from classic literature was here
who would it attack first
what would happen when you looked at it
and why would you bring out the big guns
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Cthulhu was real
Cthulhu is the most famous monster
created by the mind of H.P Lovecraft the
writer who popularized Cosmic horror
this nightmarish creature lived on earth
long before humans and now it's lurking
under the planet's crust watching using
telepathy to communicate until one of us
awakens it with the help of an elaborate
ritual
its mission to rule or destroy humanity
and wait till you encounter its most
devastating ability
unless you were a lone sailor lost in
the sea you wouldn't have much to worry
about at least not for a while
cthulhu's presence is so shocking and
incomprehensible that merely seeing it
would make you overthink your own
existence and realize how unimportant
you were
Cthulhu can break your mind and make you
go mad
and you wouldn't be alone for years
Cthulhu would attract other Wanderers
it would lead lost souls to ancient
temples where the cult of Cthulhu would
be reborn
and mind enchantment would be nothing
compared to what comes next because once
enough people were mind trapped Cthulhu
would awaken
it would emerge somewhere in the South
Pacific that's where the ancient stone
City where it sleeps is located
hungry to take over the world Cthulhu
would move to either Chile or New
Zealand
there it would begin its Rampage and
domination
your best bet to survive this atrocity
would be to shut your eyes and run away
anyone who got a good look at it would
lose their sanity the world's
governments would deploy robotic
technology to make first contact with
Cthulhu
but it would be useless nothing would
get in the way of its destruction and
collection of followers
so what could you do
well in this chaos of chaos you'd still
have three options
one accept your inability to stop
Cthulhu and join it
two run or try to
Humanity's only true escape would
involve leaving Earth in spaceships but
we lack the technology for such a
worldwide breakout and time wouldn't be
on our side
plus the monster's mind control would
still call us to it
three fight
join the resistance and Humanity's Last
Stand
to avoid going mad looking at the
monster you would need to train in
blindfolded combat
but our armies would also face off with
our new overlords foot soldiers a legion
of shape-shifting aliens created by
Cthulhu to lead its human followers
we'd need to hurry before the world
became overrun by these spawns
lucky for us Humanity counters with all
kinds of weapons
submarines with torpedoes
battleships fighter jets
but unlucky for us the minds of those
controlling these weapons could be taken
by Cthulhu to further wreak havoc and
destroy the Earth
and after our first successful attack on
the creature we'd realize it was all for
nothing
Cthulhu would quickly recover from any
Fallout of the attacks and continue
Gathering followers
yeah very unlucky indeed
sooner or later we we turn to the big
boys
nuclear weapons what's left of humanity
that isn't brainwashed would agree to
aim all of the nukes in our possession
at Cthulhu we'd blast it with the power
of 3 billion tons of TNT
but that would also lead to massive
destruction
billions of people would die and entire
continents would be made uninhabitable
the survivors would be packed into
whatever land is left and forced to deal
with the beginning of a mortal nuclear
winter
the radioactive material covering our
planet would ravage starving populations
and yet Cthulhu would remain standing
weakened but alive
the nukes would just buy us time while
Cthulhu recovered to one day face a much
weaker human race
in the end you never stood a chance
ew I'm sure glad this nightmare lives in
a book
now giant squids however surely lurk in
the depths of our oceans but
that's a monster
or another
what if
[Applause]
[Music]